Perfect. All right. So the idea of MRD-directed therapy, right, is you don't need to wait for a morphologic overt relapse.
If you can identify reliably, you know, persistent or progressing residual disease, you know, can you intervene early and then prevent the toxicity, you know, of patients who are getting therapy when they, you know, are cytopenic and have neutropenic infections,
as well as easier efficacy, right, because there's less burden of disease there.
And we talked already, you know, in the last session about various different MRD markers.
You know, some patients can have that reliable NPM1 or FLT3 FLT3 core binding factor KMT2A, but in many cases, we don't have a great specific MRD molecular or genomic base.
And so flow MRD becomes the kind of overarching currently what we're using, although in the future, I think that will change.
And just as, you know, as a background, so NPM1 is the perfect example, right?
We know in newly diagnosed NPM1 mutated patients who are in a remission, in their first remission, you know, if they become MRD negative, they have a good chance of being cured and we don't need to proceed to a transplant.
Whereas even though we say NPM1 is favorable, if they stay MRD positive, you can see that first curve, they're not doing that great, and having a transplant in first remission really improves the outcome.
So this is kind of an example of how MRD really.
Is impactful.
So the intercept study, it stands for investigating novel therapy to target early relapse and clonal evolution preemptively.
This is really the brainchild of Andrew Way and others in Australia.
And we are participating at MD Anderson as the one kind of US site in this otherwise Australian study, where you take AML in first or second remission.
They are enrolled into this master consent where you're monitoring MRD and at the time of failure, whether it's MRD failure or.
Mere morphologic relapse, which up to 15% blasts, you're then allocated to an arm based on your genomics, with the various different treatment arms shown here.
The objective, kind of generally, is to see if we can produce an improvement in MRD response rate of 40% or higher.
Certainly many other secondary objectives and just kind of drilling down a little bit more.
You know, an MRD response is defined as someone who has detectable MMR.
Right.
If you have detectable MRD, you get one log or better reduction or flow less than 0.1% within 100 days of starting this intercept directed study therapy based on the arm you're on.
We're, of course, looking at clinical endpoints of relapse free survival, how long it takes, duration of MRD response, as well as many other and a fun translational analysis being done on the samples of these patients.
Treatment is for 12 cycles.
So this was a big, you know, contentious discussion back and forth, you know.
This is a trial, but also, you know, how long, you know, similar to the conversations we've been having earlier today.
In patients who are doing well after 12 cycles that are not transitioning to transplant, there is the option to continue further.
And patients are followed for up to 24 months where you're getting these time points and getting these samples to the lab.
And I just want to highlight, there's only been one arm that has been presented to date.
So I'll just go through that because I think it's a little bit illustrative and certainly men and inhibitors are very interesting.
To those of us in the room.
So this is the reviewment of arm for patients with MRD, NPM1, or KMT2A rearranged leukemia.
So eligibility is that you have MRD relapse.
So you have a rise in the NPM1 or KMT2A.
And you have to have two MRD samples, right?
So you have your sample showing MRD is rising and then you need a repeat one about 30 days later.
And so that's why oligoblastic relapse is also allowed.
Because many of these patients are actually kind of evolving in real time into a more active disease.
14 patients have been presented to date.
And I've just highlighted the fact most of them are NPM1 mutated.
Most of them were in their first remission.
And you see the time from the documentation of MRD failure to the first day they're getting reviewment is just under two months for that reason that you need that second confirmatory MRD positive sample.
Patients in general are in.
Permission, right?
So they have good neutrophils, good platelets, good hemoglobin when they're starting treatment.
So it really gives you the opportunity to see, you know, how well these therapies are tolerable in patients who have sustained bone marrow function.
And so that's highlighted here where you just are not seeing a lot of grade three and four toxicity.
There is a 7% risk of febrile neutropenia, which, you know, compared to the reviewment in phase one of monotherapy is, you know, 31%.
And actually many of these cytopenias are actually.
Patients who are not responding and are progressing and, you know, developing kind of leukemia in the first few cycles.
But you do, you do see thrombocytopenia with reviewment in these patients.
And so this just kind of shows you that in five different patient samples during cycle one and cycle two, the fact that there is oftentimes grade two or grade three thrombocytopenia that was seen.
And of the 11 efficacy of valuable patients.
About half of them had MRD response, whether it was a greater than one log decline, which was considered the endpoint or full MRD clearance in the dark green.
There were four patients who progressed that had samples.
And you can see here, you know, we were talking about this yesterday.
You're not seeing RAS mutations evolving, you know, so that wasn't seen here either.
Interestingly, no men one variants were seen either, which to me is a little bit interesting and curious.
But you do see FLIP3-FLT3, IDH2, SIBL were the three kind of emerging mutations identified in these samples.
It takes about two to six cycles to clear MRD in the MRD setting, right?
So these are patients without a lot of bulk of disease, but it still takes a few cycles.
And you can see that just over half of them had that, you know, greater than one log reduction at any time with a relapse-free survival kind of sitting right above that.
So you can see that just over half of them had that, you know, greater than one log reduction at any time with a relapse-free survival kind of sitting right above that.
Thank you so much.